Votre Majesté nous sommes
découverts
bien
attendez on est sur la glace c'est unège
retirez-vous je ne suis pas fait comme
les autres
hommes mais ceux au pouvoir ne me voi
que comme un guerrier ne pouvant
prétendre à aucune charge
mais je marche dans les pas d'Alexandre
le Grand et de
César quel est votre nom Napoléon le
cours de ma vie vientil de changer
Napoléon je dois vous prévenir je ne ser
pas commandant
en mais c'est par le que je
l'orter iné à de grandes
[Musique]
choses j'ai trouvé la couronne de France
dans le ruisseau et je l'ai placé sur ma
tête tu crois être un grand
homme tu n'ai rien si je ne suis pas
avec
toi
Disle je pense que je parle au nom de
tous quand je dis que nous dormirons
beaucoup mieux sans cette
vermine
à qui est ce
pays à
[Musique]
moi